I'm going
good job
the wall
it's exciting that we now live in an age
where modding our games isn't a PC
exclusive thing both of the players and
the mod creators themselves mods are
more systems means more people playing
mods more people playing mods means more
creators are inspired to build awesome
custom content more awesome custom
content means more people playing mods
and thus the awesome cycle of creation
continues today on the fallout 4 show I
presents you the top 5 console mods at
least in this wasteland is humble
opinion
fallout wasteland can look pretty green
with all the radiation storms
supermutants and camouflage Gunners
shoot plasma your way that's not really
the kind of green I've been missing
green in the Commonwealth brings the
wastes of Boston to life and adds a
healthy dose of color to the usually
brown and rusted world trees are full of
green leaves grass has grown and spread
across the hills and the whole
atmosphere feels a lot more enjoyable to
be in if you'll get in some fatigue from
the fallout visuals I recommend giving
this mod a try
I was shocked with how different the
game felt after the addition of some
simple foliage
as the name suggests this is a menu that
allows you to cheat on the console
versions of Fallout 4 but considering PC
players have sneaky console commands I
think it's only fair the console players
get a leg up - after you craft the
holotape with the chemistry station the
fleet of features will be at your
disposal you'll be able to add caps add
weapons add ammo add crafting materials
stimpacks food beverages quest items
perk points born settlers encouraged
companions change the weather and even
sports behemoths all this and a lot more
if you've completed all the ingame
adventures and fallout and just want to
have some fun or you're on your second
playthrough I can't bring yourself to
farm for a decent again this model let
you do most of the silly cheesy things
that PC console commands will now go
forth and spawn 1 million caps when
fallout 4 hits shelves the dialog system
was target of some scrutiny and for good
reason the one or two words that get
given in the menu never really give you
a sense of what your character is about
to say and would often say something
completely different to what you
expected this mod completely fixes that
adding a menu that tells you exactly
what you're about to say a simple mod
that fixes a fairly big gripe no more
one-word menus no more miscommunication
no more having to load quick saves after
accidentally pissing someone off with a
very big gun Fallout New Vegas remains
my favorite Fallout game hell it's
probably one of my favorite games of all
time and I know I'm not alone with
having a sense of nostalgia for this
game and that's why this mod made it to
the list not only is a great armor mod
but it's a connection to the world of
new Vegas the new California Republic
veteran Ranger armor is the same set of
right gear you see the Rangers wear in
the previous game but a whole lot
better-lookin with improved visuals and
the ability to mod it to your heart's
content
you're able to add the iconic mask as
well as the ability to detect heat
signatures giving yourself a veteran
edge in the wasteland at the
Commonwealth the authors are also
working on the classic veteran weapon
the Ranger Sequoia so hopefully in a few
weeks your bad ass Californian ensemble
will be complete
I could have added any multitude of
great weapon mods to this list but I
figured hey why not throw in a bunch of
insane weapons with any mod any weapon
the baddies inhabiting waist level arm
themselves randomly as if they were
using the original any weapon any mod
mod which pretty much does what it says
on the tin any mod can go on any weapon
this means the weapon you end up coming
across could be anything from automatic
Fatman launchers to super long-range
revolvers swords and axes glued together
to Gatling guns that fire electricity it
does mean every now and then you'll bump
into a Raider with a gun thrice his size
but it definitely adds a sense of
tension to the game as well as making
things a little more crazy so those are
my 5 unmissable mods if you're playing
on console the sea of custom content is
just getting deeper and deeper and I'm
sure everyone out there has their
favorite so please leave your most
outstanding mods in the comments section
below or tweet them using the hashtag gs
fallout
Ivan Dave your guide to all things
irradiated and until next time stay safe
out there wasteland err